edith amantes y nos llevan más de 20
años luchando por los derechos de las
disidencias sexuales a través de su
organización let's go feminista es una
de las miles de mujeres y disidencias
sexuales que se concentraron en el
centro de santiago en un acto cultural
de la campaña electoral del izquierdista
gabriel boric para pronunciarse en
contra de la amenaza que supone la
llegada de la ultraderecha de pólvora
porque aquí hay hay una amenaza no
solamente de que coarte los derechos
sino que de una persecución y eso ya se
está viendo porque sectores de del otro
candidato de ultraderecha ya han
amenazado a organizaciones como la mía y
organizaciones trans con
persecución
al igual que otras organizaciones
denuncian más agresividad contra la
diversidad sexual en la sociedad chilena
desde la primera vuelta ocurrida hace
tan sólo un mes que tenemos el otro lado
el otro candidato es una amenaza ha
aumentado los crímenes de odio contra
personas telegénico va más desde la
primera vuelta siendo quien normalmente
nosotros ya tenemos una tasa de
alrededor de 3 crímenes de odio
semanales denuncia en el sector oriente
en uno de los barrios más adinerados de
santiago se lleva a cabo un festival de
banderas con profusión de colores del
estandarte chileno y los simpatizantes
de josé antonio kast se reunieron para
celebrar el fin de campaña de su
candidato una fiesta con música alegría
y vítores que agrupó a personas que ven
al ultraderechista como el mejor
candidato
hizo demasiado la situación política
cada uno representa lo contrario del
otro yo considero que en este minuto
josé antonio que representa mucho más
mis ideales si se encuentra en una
encrucijada de caminos y lado gabriel
boric y avanzar a los cambios demandados
en la revuelta social o revertir esa vía
de vuelta a los ideales conservadores de
jose antonio kast el voto de este
domingo marcará como nunca antes en un
sentido u otro diametralmente opuestos
el futuro de los chilenos